lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en la multiplicación de
fracciones digamos que tenemos dos
tercios y queremos multiplicarlo por
cuatro a cuánto va a ser igual pausa
este vídeo e intenta pensarlo por ti
mismo
muy bien trabajemos juntos en esto para
ayudarnos usaré una recta numérica y
digamos que cada una de estas marcas
representa un tercio esto es 0 esto es
un tercio dos tercios tres tercios
cuatro tercios cinco tercios seis
tercios siete tercios ocho tercios y
nueve tercios entonces donde es dos
tercios por uno bueno dos tercios por
uno es igual a dos tercios solo damos un
salto a dos tercios de modo que eso es
dos tercios x uno si multiplicamos dos
tercios por dos serán dos saltos así que
tenemos una vez dos tercios
dos tercios tres dos tercios y luego
cuatro dos tercios solo hicimos cuatro
saltos de dos tercios cada uno podrías
ver esto como dos tercios más dos
tercios más dos tercios más dos tercios
y a donde llegamos llegamos a ocho
tercios fíjate dos tercios por cuatro es
igual a ocho tercios ahora podríamos ir
hacia el otro lado podríamos mirar una
recta numérica y pensar en maneras de
representar lo que nos muestra la recta
numérica en khan academy tenemos algunos
ejemplos de problemas que lo hacen de
esa manera así que pensé que sería bueno
hacer un ejemplo así etiquetemos esta
recta numérica un poco diferente en
lugar de que cada una de estas líneas
representen un tercio
digamos que representan un medio aquí
tenemos cero un medio dos medios tres
medios cuatro medios cinco medios seis
medios siete medios ocho medios y nueve
medios
digamos que vemos algo como esto que
solo viéramos esta representación voy a
tratar de dibujarlo así si solo viéramos
esta representación qué tipo de
multiplicación está tratando de
representar bueno podrías ver eso como
tres medios más otros tres medios más
otro tres medios porque fíjate cada uno
de estos altos son tres un medio o tres
medios de modo que podrías ver esto como
tres medios más tres medios más tres
medios otra forma de pensar en esto es
que son tres altos de tres medios
también puedes ver esto como tres por
tres medios ya que es igual bueno tres
medios más tres medios más tres medios o
tres por tres medios te lleva a nueve
medios